president biden once again blaming
others for his catastrophic failure on
kovid if you want to test you're going
to have to wait long lines are the norm
as panicked americans all across the
country scramble to find tests and this
could be why back in october the bite
administration rejected a proposal for
free rapid tests for the holidays the
president trying to reassure frustrated
governors on a video call earlier but he
just wound up blaming them
look there is no
federal solution this gets solved at the
state level seeing how tough it was for
some folks to get a test this weekend
shows that we have
more work to do when i took office 10
months into the we were 10 months into
the pandemic and even so we had no zero
over-the-counter home test in the united
states so we got to work we quadruple a
number of pharmacies offering a free
test
and there are now more than 20 000
places where you can get tested for free
for over-the-counter at-home tests as i
said
there
there were none when we took office none
now we have eight on the market it's
clearly not enough if i had we'd known
we would have gone
harder quicker if we could have we still
have tens of millions of unvaccinated
people
and we're seeing hospitalizations rise
and even dr facchi thinks biden fumbled
the ball on testing
you know testing has always been an
issue caitlyn that has been problematic
it has been compounded by the situation
of the high demands we had a conflation
of high demands high demands because of
the concern about omicron which is a
justifiable concern but the high demand
that was triggered by the holiday season
not making any excuses for it we should
have had more tests available but
hopefully now as we get into the first
couple of weeks in january that'll get
much better
and dr marty mccary is ripping into
biden's handling of the situation
it's disappointing that we're just
hearing this sort of political hot air
because there's a lot of important
things right now that the white house
could be talking about that they're not
talking about for one
they need to announce a selective
testing strategy they cannot recommend
universal testing with the limited
supply that we're currently rationing
and some big news from the cdc after
shortening their quarantine guidance for
those who test positive to five days
they're now saying the individuals who
have received their booster shot do not
need to quarantine at all following an
exposure but should wear a mask for 10
days so
tyrus uh seems like the government
created quite the mess for themselves
here
you know i this is where i just and
again i'm not a rocket surgeon but i do
read a lot of books
we have been literally being told since
this administration came into power that
we are all defcom red kovetkovit kovet
we can't go to work unless we have
tested or we're vaccinated all these
things so why would we not have stuff
why would they refuse stuff when their
entire pitch this entire administration
is that kovit wasn't going anywhere and
they were going to be prepared and once
again fantasy world the woke
administration they're not prepared and
so what really and you hate to be the
conspiracy guy i never want to be that
guy so omicron came on and you had to
they're telling you that you had to
quarantine for at least 10 days lo and
behold you can't go back to work until
you get a test saying that you don't
have it anymore so now people have to
wait to get back to work so what are the
lo and behold the cdc comes out with
we'll cut it to five if you have your
booster we'll cut it to none
i just wow when are they ever just gonna
just be accountable and tell us
tell us the real what is exactly going
on instead it's just more of the same
and americans are confused frustrated
and rightfully so
so jason you know president biden
campaigned on shutting down the virus
not shutting down the country and then
today magically he admits that this is
not a federal government problem as he
fails to deliver on that promise
well yeah after beating up for i don't
know the entire year on places like
texas and florida and those types of
things voila it's not a federal problem
hey it's you the governors you got to do
it meanwhile we're going to go ahead and
do federal mandates on work requirements
on masks on airplanes on all kinds of
things you're going to do do all those
types of mandates but you've had two
years to work on this mr president then
you come out to the world and say
i forgot to order more masks like you
forgot to go to the grocery store and
order you know bring home the the
avocados that that's forgetting
something you don't forget to order
literally billions of tests and then you
told people on december 2nd that you
could go down and get one for free but
that isn't going to happen either oh hey
we've got to wait until january in order
to do this and i tell you what if you're
intellectually
consistent for those of you that were
critical of donald trump saying on day
one that he didn't have enough testing
certainly two years into this you got to
take that same position and say joe
biden kamala harris what have you been
doing because it hasn't been working on
on covet i still don't understand what
their plan is
so richard you know biden used this as a
political uh point on the campaign draw
he bludgeoned donald trump over it
repeatedly there's tweets of him saying
that the president is behind
on testing and yet here we are
a year into his presidency with this
story in vanity fair saying he rejected
this massive testing plan ahead of
another variant which we were told by
experts for the past two years would
eventually happen what what happened
there
look i'll give you this i think that we
could all agree that the white house was
a day behind a dollar short day late in
a dollar straight when it comes to
testing overall and making sure that
every american had access to a test but
with that being said they think they
acknowledge that today and i think other
than that what you see happening all
across the country is that people are
able to go and get at home tests i was
able to go get a home test at my local
fire station right here in the nation's
capital but beyond that i think what was
the most news breaking or newsworthy
thing out of today's sort of meeting
with the governors is the fact that both
fauci and the president are really
interested in switching the definition
of how they define the impact of coping
19 and instead of looking at infection
rates what you see them saying is we
need to be looking towards
hospitalizations because the omicron
variant is just spreading just so fast
that we have to figure out a new way to
evaluate how is america going to be kept
safe understanding that we have to live
with this virus for some time and
understanding that it's impacting our
health care system and our healthcare
workers more so than any other sector so
i'm happy to see that the white house is
moving in the right direction when it
comes to changing the definition of what
they're more concerned about less about
infections more about hospitalizations
so rachel speaking of those hospitals
getting
go ahead
i just everybody's known that we they've
been counting uh not counting cases
they've been counting uh county cases
instead of uh hospitalization that's
what was their problem from the get-go
here's what i don't understand marty
mccary said it very well if they have a
shortage of of of tests they should
absolutely prioritize those who need it
most the elderly those with
comorbidities but doing that would you
know tell basically expose the lies of
this administration everybody's going to
get coveted we now know that and what i
don't understand is if everybody's going
to get coveted and this variant is very
mild wouldn't this be a great time to
start talking about herd immunity to be
talking about early treatments that
people can do at home to be talking
about natural immunities i i don't
understand why they keep doing jabs only
as the only solution to this
problem it doesn't make any sense if we
have limited tests save them for those
who need it most
so jason you know back to you real
quickly you know on this issue of this
testing shortage the government created
it by dr fauci essentially telling
everybody they need to test before they
went home to see grandma and grandpa for
christmas and now we have all of these
people who are
not showing symptoms showing up by the
hundreds to these testing centers so
didn't they put themselves in this
position especially after rejecting this
plan to develop more tests
yeah you need kids to go you have to
have testing in order to go school or
play in sports they have to do it on the
sports field they're taking really
healthy 20 year olds and saying hey you
got to get a test you know what if
you're overweight you're over 65 you're
in the hospital you've got a comobiti
morbidity as rachel was talking about
yeah then save the test for them but not
everybody especially those that aren't
showing any symptoms they don't need to
go get a test
but here's the problem how about if they
spread this spread that to somebody who
has a comorbidity
yeah well i would just say that that's
the administration
and they really haven't been able to
handle that hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else